This video is brought to you by Epic games.
What's up wisecrack Michael here in 1987 in 1995,
two movies about futuristic crime fighters were box office hits. Well,
one was a hit and the other was a huge flop. Oh, okay. Okay.
Let me try it again. In 1987 and 1995,
two movies about futuristic crime fighters sold tickets across North America,
Robocop and judge dread at first,
these films might seem like just two more additions to the dumb action foot
cannon about the forces of good racking up that guy,
body counts in the name of justice boat.
What if they're actually doing a lot more like asking some really big questions,
questions like how should a society enforce its laws at the loader?
And more importantly,
what if they're secretly commenting and how these guys answered that question?
Let's find out in this wisecrack condition on a Robocop and judge Dredd,
who is the.
And of course spoilers ahead.
But before we continue, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor fortnight to catch you up to speed.
Fortnite is an Epic battle Royale game.
You drop out of a flying battle bus with a hundred players and fight to become
the last man standing the game season for chapter two, nexus war just dropped.
So if you haven't picked up the game before now is the time to play.
The battle pass is pretty stacked since the new skins include some of your
favorite Marvel heroes like storm iron man mystique, Dr. Dune, Wolverine,
she hope and even groups. The game has also updated its maps.
So you can now battle in Marvel's most iconic location like dooms domain,
central graveyard, and more.
There'll be like your own private version of the next Marvel installment and
good news guys. Iron man is still alive too soon.
If you finished last season's battle pass and are ready for a new challenge now
is the time to hop on if you've never played before,
make sure you download the game today. Using the link in the description,
the game is free to download and available on PC PS4, Xbox, and switch.
So check it out now,
back to the show before filmmaker Paul Verhoeven and screenwriter,
Edward Neumeier brought us this.
Here's a bunch of MIT kids that looked like they could eat bugs for lunch.
They brought us Robocop in a futuristic dystopian, Detroit,
the mega corporation, Omni consumer products,
OCP wins a contract to run the city's police department after cutting funding so
that the cops can't do their jobs properly.
They leave police officer Alex Murphy to a gang of criminals led by the dad from
that 70 show Murphy is murder and OCP looking for a Guinea pig,
rebuilds them as a cost saving cyborg that is programmed to.
Serve the public trust protects the innocent.
Eight years later, judge Dredd premiered sliced alones. Judge Joseph dread.
Isn't a robot, but a heavily armored street.
Judge who patrols mega city one in this 2080 totalitarian police state law is
maintained by street judges who serve as judge, jury,
and executioner dread basically worships the law and is very good at
implementing it with catchphrases like a new you'd say until he gets
framed for murder. You're under arrest.
What's the charge murder Robocop.
And judge Dredd have a lot of similarities and it's not just the coed locker
rooms. They're both stories about crime,
run a muck and the increasingly desperate and ethically questionable means of
containing it. Importantly,
both the worlds of Robocop and judge Dredd see law enforcement, outgunned,
and ill-equipped to maintain order. Alex Murphy for instance,
gets gunned down in part because backup is unavailable now,
whereas that backup backup is still on available. And even judge dreads,
please state still can't seem to keep up with the riff Raff.
Some cultural context is important in the 1960s and 1970s.
The violent crime rate in America increased by 126% 1980s
brought the crack cocaine epidemic and handgun related homicides doubled between
1985 and 1990 crime was heavily reported on and sensationalized by the
media and became a frequent talking point of political campaigns while most
millennials and zoomers have lived their entire lives in a world with decreasing
crime rates. The same cannot be said for the original audiences of these films.
The idea that street savages had made the laws.
We know it collapsed as the judge Dredd intro tells us was a familiar idea to
anyone watching the five o'clock news. And for those terrified by crime,
something like this,
we're projecting the end of crime in old Detroit within 40 days,
was this stuff a fantasies at first glance,
one might assume these films were all aboard the pants over a crime epidemic
train, but both of these films are subversive commentaries on these fears,
not simple reflections of them for judge dread.
The logical conclusion of being tough on crime is this
whereas Robocop warns us about the dangers of fear-mongering and a for-profit
criminal justice system. I say good business is where you find it.
As you know,
we've entered into a contract with the city to run local law enforcement,
but the,
or these films commentary has less to do with this topic predictions about
policing and everything to do with this guy, Earl Warren,
chief justice of the U S Supreme court from 1953 to 1969 Warren headed the
court through ruling.
So world changing that it's hard to imagine a time before them. Of course,
there's the big hits like Brown vs board of ed,
which desegregate schools and loving versus Virginia,
which legalized interracial marriage. But there's also the Miranda warning.
You have the right to remain silent, which was not a thing.
Some sweaty wig wearing founding father came up with,
but rather the result of a 1966 case involving a guy named Ernesto Miranda,
it was the Warren court's decisions dealing with criminal justice,
like the Miranda case that made him the hire of conservative politicians and a
result in scapegoat for society's problems.
Remember those exploding crime rates.
It wasn't the lack of economic opportunity or access to guns or funding cuts for
all types of social services. Nope.
It was all the fault of our man Earl as McCall Belk nap rights before Warren
became chief justice.
Few politicians would have thought to blame the Supreme for the crime rate,
but the blame they did and the criticisms lobbied at Warren fuel the satire and
commentary driving bolt dread and Robocop.
So why all the hate it's because Warren's court laid forth an entire new set of
protections for our constitutional rights.
When dealing with the police affirming the right to remain silent,
the right to a lawyer,
the right to have that lawyer present during police interrogation and protection
from the use of illegally seized evidence critics like of former New York city
police commissioner argued that these protections stifled law enforcement
weakening a police force that was already stretched,
dangerously thin unsurprisingly pop culture reflected these anxieties.
Most obviously in cinema,
which depicted endless streams of good guy hero cops who refused to play by the
pesky Warren style rules pleasing, you know,
the loose cannon who could just get the bad guy.
If it weren't for all the red tape in his way, in this context,
who would be the ultimate answer to Warren error restrictions,
the ultimate unencumbered cop.
How about a guy who is perfectly internalized the criminal justice coding and
must be trusted to enforce the law fairly, no matter what sounds kind of.
This serve the public trust protects the innocent,
uphold the law or this, it goes 36, 13.
First degree murder street, judge,
I guess life.
Judge Dredd imagines a freed from bureaucracy,
an officer's so thoroughly trained in the law.
He doesn't need a balance of powers to justly, administer it. A copy.
Doesn't have to worry about activist judges because he is the judge who won't be
stopped by sympathetic juries because he is the jury.
And of course he's also the one handling the punishment.
Summary executions by judge dreads.
Dread is the platonic ideal of a cop. He isn't driven by emotions.
And emotions.
There ought to be a log and.
Doesn't have any friends that could create a conflict of interest.
He has simply memorized the law and will Dole it out without any bias or
compassion he is to inner city policing and what your Roomba is to midsize
department vacuuming. Of course,
this is the target of the film's critique without a balance of powers who is to
save dread when he's on trial, his own biceps.
[Inaudible].
Earlier in the film dread arrest, a spaghetti covered rod Schneider,
who was just trying to avoid a shootout. They were killing each other.
Could've gone out the window, 40 floors. It would be suicide baby,
but it's legal.
Once they later team up, he can't even give deuce big,
lower casual my bed because the law.
Can apologize on Robocop. Also.
Incorporates many of the defining traits of Lauren's critics is specially the
eventual successor to Warren Warren Earl burger.
I know it's too many Warren's in Earl's before he took the other Earl's job.
Berger complained about a drawn-out legal process where criminals could bank on
their free lawyer, getting them off on a technical loophole. Of course,
many of those loopholes were civil rights protections concocted by the Warren
court,
like the hypothetical drug dealer who gets off because the cops don't have a,
we see hints of this narrative in Robocom like a slimy criminal defense lawyer
in the intro.
There's murder. It's not like he killed someone.
It's just a clear violation of my client's civil rights,
make it aggravated assault, and I can make bail in cash now. And a guy.
Screaming that he's a repeat offender.
I am what you call a repeat offender. I repeat
offender again.
Sensibly because the justice system can't legally lock him up for good one.
Man who catapulted his career straight into the white house by criticizing
Warren was one Richard Milhous Nixon after an explosion of violent protests
and riots swept the country in the long hot summer of 1967,
soon to be presidential candidate Richard Nixon published an op-ed titled what
has happened to America.
One of his scapegoats judges weakening the police's ability to fight cry.
A point that Nixon would continue to repeat throughout his presidency.
I believe some of the sessions I've gone to a fall
in the past and weakening the peace forces as against the
criminal forces in our society.
In fact is Bob Woodward and Scott Armstrong put it in the brethren burger was
chosen by Nixon to lead the Supreme court specifically because of his ragging on
Warren's criminal justice decisions while Robocop and judge Dredd came out well
after Nixon's impeachment is tough on crime and antiwar in court rhetoric
persisted well into the eighties and nineties.
Bob.
You surprise them that Robocops cartoonishly evil,
backstabbing criminals and judge dreads disintegrating social order seemed like
a warning from this Richard Nixon ad, which tells us.
In recent years,
crime in this country has grown nine times as fast as population.
And to vote like your whole world depended on it.
The idea that civilization itself was being threatened by crime was and
continues to be a common warning and political rhetoric criminals.
Aren't your friendly neighborhood. We delivery guy,
a person trying to make ends meet,
or someone pushed into desperation by addiction.
They are irredeemable monsters willing to betray each other at a whim and
destroy their own neighborhood in the process.
When the police go on strike and Robocop,
the city quickly devolves into violent anarchy,
this kind of rhetoric wasn't limited to the likes of Nixon,
how the U S was handling crime continued to be of great public concern in the
eighties and nineties law and order rhetoric research during the Reagan years.
And not because he started a movie of the same name.
Even bill Clinton took a tough on crime stance and Hillary Clinton in 1996,
warned of child super predators with no conscience or empathy.
They are often the kinds of kids that are called super predators, no conscience,
no empathy.
There's even a rumor that Hillary screened Robocop for the white house staff,
and then told them, now you go make this happen. That rumor was,
of course started right now by me with literally no evidence to support it.
Other than it would be crazy if that happened. Right?
Of course she wasn't the first to accuse criminals of being inhuman monsters.
She was just putting her own spin on familiar rhetoric.
Robocop takes this concept and pushes it to 11,
giving us the least sympathetic villains possible before assaulting a woman,
two men act like zoo.
Animals.
Well, the dad from that 70 show uses a wounded friend to slow down a police car.
And judge dread the people who exist outside the law are literal.
I forgot to mention it. Your new friends,
they're cannibals.
Even as a copy of the decline and fall of the Roman empire in his locker,
suggesting the stakes of the war against crime are in his mind,
the decline and fall of the Western civilization.
But these movies are ultimately criticizing this narrative,
even policing with an iron fist, can't save judge dreads, mega cities.
And the most inventive thing this guy has to offer is more executions.
The only solution is a tougher criminal code and.
And if our criminal justice system could clone perfect cops like dread,
it could do nothing to stop gross abuses of power without a separate judicial
system to stop it. Meanwhile,
Robocop through artfully placed commercials suggest that there's a perverse
incentive for the media to report on the chaos of the world so that OCP can
deploy extremely profitable murder robots to save civilization.
The criminal justice system in both films are willing to go to extreme lengths
in the name of stopping perps,
even though they're inflicting a ton of collateral damage with little
consideration for the complexities of criminal activity, these worlds,
both full of law enforcers don't seem very lawful at all.
In other action movies of the time,
vigilante justice is a noble alternative to policing.
If the cops can't get the job done, I will. The good guys kill the bad guys.
And everyone goes home happy.
And maybe wondering if there are too many Warren style rules,
obstructing cops from doing their jobs in contrast Robocop,
and judge Dredd are making fun of both the tropes and anxieties of the time.
These films,
satirize romantic notions of good guy cops in a world unencumbered by red tape.
They can also help us ask questions about how and when our desire for law and
order compromises our other values like democracy or the belief in a separation
of powers in the criminal justice system.
But what do you guys think are Robocop and judge Dredd,
brilliant indictments of tough on crime rhetoric and policies.
Let us know in the comments. Huge,
thanks to our patrons for your support as always,
thanks for watching and sadistically murdered that subscribe button.
And remember, I am the law later.